so what does this all mean for the
future of the Republican Party 2024
presidential race so here live pictures
here of a courtroom in Miami where the
recently debosed president Trump has
just been charged with 37 counts 37
involving classified documents of the
most top secret stuff involving
America's apparently evolving America's
nuclear program uh its plans for
potentially attacking enemy States and
so on very sensitive stuff that he
shouldn't have had in the first place
and then when he was asked to hand him
back according to the indictment he
didn't had a lot of it back
um so these are serious things and you
can explain away Trump defend him as
much as you want feel like you know he's
getting a hard time the indictment is
serious when you read it joining me now
is the conservative radio host Ben
Ferguson the host of the Reuben report
Dave Rubin all right guys uh there's a
battle raging here now for the soul of
the Republican party and a real quandary
what does the Republican Party do about
this growing number of legal issues that
Donald Trump is facing Ben Ferguson yeah
where are we here Donald Trump all right
yeah the storm be Daniel stuff you can
sort of joke that away say it's trivial
bit of a Witch Hunt stupid I don't
disagree with that particularly but this
stuff when I read the indictment is very
serious if this was Joe Biden and it was
level to him or Obama you would be
leading the charge probably to have him
executed
not executed but I would be leading the
charge uh for classified documents if
you're going to have this level of
accountability for a republican then
then damn it you better do it for
everybody on the left that has also done
this and there was no accountability and
this is going to be why this is not a
big issue in the primary for Donald
Trump there was their accountability for
Hillary Clinton the three thousand
thirty thousand plus emails literally
telling her staff to take hammers to
blackberries and cell phones zero
accountability and that's going to be
the talking point for Donald Trump I
think he actually gets closer to the
nomination uh today with this indictment
because there are so many Americans
conservatives that are sick and tired of
a two-tier justice system where this
system goes after Republicans and looks
the other way when there's meetings on
tarmacs uh between former President Bill
Clinton uh and the Attorney General
talking about Hillary Clinton they've
had enough of it now does that mean that
this is going to be a good thing for the
Republicans and the Gen General I think
it's way too soon to tell peers But
ultimately right now there's a lot of
pissed off Americans that are sick and
tired of this two justice system here
and there's a lot of examples of it I
mean for goodness sakes look at the day
they charged him you've got Intel that
apparently five million dollars went
from one of the executives at barisma in
a bribery scheme to the sitting
president United States of America and
the majority of the mainstream media was
silent on it so okay are people shocked
by this no they're not they're angry
over it let me bring in Dave though
because the issue to me is there's also
a political element to this and if I'm a
republican it's rapidly coming a point
when you have clear options I mean you
could have Ron DeSantis I went down to
Florida interview I thought it was
pretty impressive he's a genuine
conservative he's been wildly successful
in Florida turning a 33 000 majority
into one and a half million he's Trump
without the baggage he's very trumpian
in all of his policies you know Trump's
tried to rubbish him and rubbish what
he's achieved he's obviously in my
estimation be nonsense that charge why
would the Republicans want to pursue the
Trump Road to nomination when it's so
fraught with potential danger and when
he might be the only person that could
actually let Joe Biden win
well the short answer to that is that
Trump does have a certain captivation
over the world in the last you know
decade or so that allows people to
follow him whether things are working or
not working look at the moment I agree
with you and with Ben on this idea that
the the thing that people are most upset
by at the moment is the selective
prosecution and persecution of Donald
Trump when they see the asymmetry that
Biden and Hillary and and even Mike
Pence says VP can get away with
classified document things and Donald
Trump can't that asymmetry is what
bothers people but on the DeSantis front
I I completely agree with you peers we
have what I think and you know I I moved
to Florida during covid in large part
because of Ron DeSantis and moved my
family here in two companies here and I
have a ton of flourishing people that
I'm around now in a state that is
functioning I would say really at the
Pinnacle of the world for Freedom right
now uh we have a guy who has done
everything he has set out to do in his
legislative agenda he has fought the
woke he has got the neo-racism out of
the schools he's gotten the gender stuff
out in effect he beat Disney he's doing
all of the things that anyone who is
conservative minded or or right-leaning
or roughly Republican or even a
disaffected liberal which there's a lot
of people I think you're probably a
little bit in that category uh I think
he's the guy that can get everybody out
of this but but that's sort of a
separate issue than what the base of the
base the carry Lake types who I like how
she's on one hand calling you a sellout
and then also saying God bless you I
love talking to you uh that they're
never they're never going to leave the
they're never going to leave the Trump
orbit but I think there Ron DeSantis
offers a chance for a whole bunch of new
people to come into the fold Trump I
just don't see where the new people are
even putting aside all of the
indictments and the craziness where are
the new Trump voters that's a good
question yeah let me bring Ben back on
that I mean the real issue is who can
win the independence for example yeah I
just don't see Independence exactly
liking any of the this they're all just
looking at this aghast and I don't
disagree with you by the way there are
legitimate allegations of double
standards in the way that Hillary's
emails and Joe Biden's documents and so
on have been treated by the liberal
skewed mainstream media I completely
agree with that but purely on Trump and
what he's done here and what we
apparently are going to hear from his
own voice on a tape where he concedes
these are not Declassified documents
contrary to everything he's been saying
this is a real Sword of Damocles hanging
over the party and you could end up with
the most damaged candidate in history
and that might be the only way Biden
notwithstanding all his issues ends up
winning so why is the Smart play for the
Republicans not to go for a much safer
option of yeah right it's a great
question look I like Rhonda Santos I I
said this I don't want a Civil War the
night after Rhonda santis announced and
I said if you took Donald Trump's name
and referred to him as Ken at a and you
took the Sandra's name off a page and
say can it be both of those candidates
the Republican Party would be jumping up
and down and screaming over the
difference though appears as this
there's a big asterisk now next to any
accusations against Donald Trump and the
reason why many Americans than in this
especially in this primary and going
into the general are saying we don't
believe you when you tell us that Donald
Trump's a bad person you said he was
colluding with the Russians we now know
that the Deep State lied to us the top
FBI and CIA directors were lying to us
and they signed that letter also saying
the hunter by laptop was not real not
authentic and it was had the markings of
the Russian government
again
I know the line you're taking on this
and I don't disagree with you I thought
the Russian collusion thing was a load
of trumped up nonsense no pun intended I
thought the way that the uh Hunter Biden
laptop thing was suppressed uh by big
Tech was outrageous
um but ultimately this we are where we
are and I still I still believe I still
believe that the Trump route to victory
for the Republicans in 2024 is fraught
with danger
um
he's gonna make is he's going to say Do
you believe me or believe them because
there are lots of people lots of Mega
supporters that will believe him David
final question for you
um
who is going to win the nomination give
me a name
I really think Ron DeSantis is going to
win the nomination I think the polls are
closing I think the more people get to
see him get to see the competence the
clarity his ability to communicate the
right ideas C is track record he's 44
years old he's younger than me he's got
three young kids fantastic wife in the
first lady of Florida Casey DeSantis I
think he's got the right message without
the baggage and I think as time goes on
I think you're right Pierce people are
getting tired of this that is not an
excuse related to The Selective
persecution of trump but people everyone
has a limit to how much they can take
and I'm hearing from an awful lot of
people when I travel the country they're
like we thank Trump we appreciate Trump
he woke us up he red pilled us but that
doesn't mean he has to be king forever
[Music]
guys I'm gonna leave her there but it
reminds me very much of our situation
with Boris Johnson in this country look
at the donations does Santa's got a lot
of money coming in follow that as well
because there's a lot of people out
there writing him big checks right now
and people said oh he's dead in the
water I don't think he is at all
honestly the debates also I would look
at the scores on the board as DeSantis
told me when I interviewed him I'm a
scores on the board guy and he wins and
Trump in the last few years has been a
perennial loser if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell